[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau 7 8 sociétés votre
rendez vous hebdomadaire pour débattre
discuter échanger sur ces seuls thèmes
qui font l'actualité
plus de 9500 actes de cruauté envers les
animaux et de mauvais traitements ont
été enregistrées en 2018 selon la
gendarmerie nationale 46 mille bêtes ont
été abandonnées en 2019
un quart au cours des grandes vacances
alors pour tenter de réduire ces
chiffres les députés ont adopté ce
vendredi 29 janvier une proposition de
loi visant à renforcer la lutte contre
la maltraitance animale mais la loi
va-t-elle assez loin je vous propose
d'échanger sur ce sujet avec nos deux
invités
aurore bergé bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
députée de la 10e circonscription des
yvelines est responsable du texte pour
la majorité et jacques charles fombonne
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
de la société protectrice des animaux
alors avant d'échanger avec vous je vous
propose de regarder un sujet parce que
le 22 janvier dernier aurore bergé vous
vous êtes rendu avec laeticia romero
dias député de l'essonne et rapporteur
de la loi à la fondation brigitte bardot
il faudra bientôt montrer patte blanche
pour adopter détenir un animal les
futurs adoptants ne pourront plus
trouver leur chien ou leur chat dans des
animaleries avec la loi sur la
maltraitance animale les amoureux des
bêtes devons notamment obtenir un
certificat de connaissances celui qui
devient propriétaire saura à quoi il
s'engage sera ce qu'on attend de lui et
ça lui permettra d'être mieux éclairer
sur son choix parce qu'on peut avoir
envie d'un chien mais peut-être que
c'est pas la bonne catégorie 2 chiens la
bonne taille parce que telle ou telle
espèce requiert plus d'attention et peut
être aussi plus de soins vétérinaires à
terme des sanctions plus lourdes en cas
de maltraitance qu'elle soit volontaire
ou liées à la méconnaissance de l'animal
les peines encourues vont de 1 à 5 ans
d'emprisonnement l'amande peut monter
jusqu'à soixante quinze mille euros
parmi les autres articles de la loi
l'interdiction progressive d'animaux
sauvages
les cirques et les élevages de visons
pour leur fourrure ce que je souhaite
aujourd'hui ce qui n'existe pas en
france mais je préfère qu'on pose des
garde-fous c'est qu'on élargisse cette
interdiction à l'ensemble des animaux
sauvages de manière à ce qu'on est pas
demain l'idée de quelqu'un d'ouvrir un
élevage de fourrure de renard par
exemple un texte attendu par les
associations à bazoches sur guyonne la
fondation brigitte bardot accueille
plusieurs centaines de compagnons à
quatre pattes chats chiens et animaux de
ferme
c'est très important de voir qu'il ya
enfin une réponse politique à la tante
sociétale nous ça fait des décennies
maintenant qu'on travaille avec les
politiques successifs sans obtenir aucun
résultat alors cette proposition de loi
elle ne répond pas à toutes nos attentes
bien évidemment il ya des sujets comme
la chasse l'élevage intensif la corrida
et d'autres qui ne sont pas abordées
mais ça amorce un changement et ça c'est
véritablement nouveau la loi doit être
examiné à l'assemblée nationale jusqu'au
29 janvier
la france compte 63 millions d'animaux
de compagnie injustement cette loi elle
est bien passé à l'assemblée nationale
elle a été adoptée
aurore bergé tout s'est bien passé le
texte est celui que vous aviez préparé
lors de la commission
exactement c'est un texte qui est
vraiment une première et qui a une
avancée majeure pour celles et ceux qui
depuis de nombreuses années nous alerte
et font en sorte tout simplement rang
que les droits des animaux soient mieux
reconnus ils n'essaient pas le changer
complètement le rapport entre l'homme et
l'animal on vous impose pas de tenir
vegan on souhaite pouvoir avoir encore
évidemment des français qu'ils soient
propriétaires de chats de chiens de
chevaux par contre on change la donne on
change les règles du jeu mieux
accompagner mieux responsabiliser les
futurs acquéreurs propriétaire on change
aussi les lieux au sein desquels vous
allez pouvoir adopter un animal parce
qu'on considère qu'il faut adopter un
animal à l'acheter si ce n'est dans un
élevage parce que les choses sont
extrêmement encadrées donc n'a voté dans
la loi
l'arrêt de la vente des chiens et des
chats en animalerie
par exemple pour éviter les achats
compulsifs vous savez ce petit chiot
adorable vous voyez derrière une vitre
qui vous fait craquer parce qu'il fait
craquer votre enfant et lairière vous
n'êtes pas forcément préparée à
l'arrivée de cet animal dans votre foyer
aux contraintes que ça peut générer
mieux accompagner responsabiliser mieux
sanctionner aussi ceux qui se rendent
coupables d'actes de sévices de cruauté
envers les animaux de trois ans à 56 et
entraîne la mort de l'animal et puis le
respect de l'animal sauvage notamment
l'arrêt des animaux sauvages dans les
cirques itinérants parce que à la vie et
à la physiologie d'un animal sauvage des
religions d'un éléphant ne permet
évidemment pas qu'il soit trimballé de
cirque le cirque et je crois que voilà
on a vraiment grâce à cette proposition
lors que nous avons porté nos députés
je crois changer la donne durablement du
marché
alors justement selon le baromètre
annuel de la fondation 30 millions
d'amis 69 % des français estiment que
les animaux sont mal défendue par les
politiques et 68% des français estiment
que le gouvernement ne prend pas
suffisamment en compte cette question
est ce qu'avec cette loi vous espérez
déjà que cela change
ce sentiment que peuvent avoir les
français oui mais vous savez il avait
raison il avait raison de presque en
vérité aucune majorité n'avait jamais
porté une loi qui permettait de mieux
protéger de mieux encadrer de mieux
responsabiliser de mieux sanctionner
donc c'est une avancée très
significative ces cas toujours des gens
qui vous diront que ça ne va pas assez
loin sur tel ou tel sujet mais je crois
qu'il faut regarder quand même nous on
vient du cette question se dire que on
aura plus d'animal sauvage dans les
cirques
le doc on aura plus de dell de dauphins
ou d'orques dans des delphinariums se
dire qu'on pourra plus acheter un chat
ou un char l'animalerie se dire qu'on va
enfin encadrer la vente sur internet se
dire que donné la mort un animal ce sera
plus juste une simple contravention mais
un délit qui pourra entraîner une peine
de prison
sa chance de manière très significative
le droit dans notre pays et la france
qui était malheureusement lanterne rouge
en la matière je crois qu'elle pas
nouveau
voilà être sur le devant de la scène et
enfin on répond aussi à des demandes qui
étaient des demandes portées par les
associations comme les hommes et les
devants les sites payants
il faut être très honnête ya une
pression très forte mobilisation serait
pas eu nos concitoyens et c'est ce qui a
permis aussi que la loi puisse avancer
justement vous le disais la sp a été
avec nous jacques charles fong
j'imagine que cette loi vous vous
attendiez vous l'espériez oui on
l'attendait on laisse berekum comme dit
madame berger il ya deux points pour
n'espérez pas avoir passé qui nous
paraissent fondamentaux c'est
effectivement l'encadrement très strict
pour ne pas dire l'interdiction la vente
sur internet et surtout l'interdiction
de la vente dans les animaleries
ça nous paraît fou n'a cédé combat qu'on
mène depuis très longtemps sur lequel
nous allons en pagne de communication de
fin d'année je dirais que c'est une
housse est une excellente surprise parce
que ce sont deux amendements qui ont été
rajoutées au texte initial et est
vraiment ne croyait pas non c'est parce
que le lâcha pardon dans une animalerie
qu'est-ce qui vous poser problème vous à
la spa sur cette manière de faire pour
avoir un compagnon
il ya un problème de fond il ya un
problème de mise en oeuvre si j'ose dire
le problème de fond c'est à dire que
nous considérons qu'il n'est pas
possible que l'animal soit considérée
comme une marchandise
alors évidemment c'est un bien mais le
code civil le code c'est le code rural
nous disent que c'est un être doux et de
sensibilité
donc la marchandisation d'un animal
n'est pas possible
ensuite vous avez sur internet et dans
une certaine mesure dans la vente les
animaleries des pratiques d'importation
des pratiques de sevrage précoce des
pratiques de certainement d'euthanasie
puisque vous le voyez dans les
animaleries que les chiens vous ne voyez
que des chatons que deviennent les à
l'humour ce qu'ils sont adultes et vous
avez une mise en scène de l'animal qui
est en fait un produit d'appel les gens
le week-end sésé séko metz le
reconnaissent eux mêmes et c'est une
logique de vente
ça n'est pas une logique d'adoption et
ça n'est pas une logique non plus de
d'achat d'un animal chez un éleveur
avec cette différence avec une
animalerie c'est que l'éleveur connaît
la souche les animaux naissent chez lui
alors que les autres sont achetés sont
importés souvent depuis dans laquelle la
réglementation pour les animaux n'est
pas aussi strictes que la nôtre alors
que dans le même temps les fourrières
euthanasique des dizaines de milliers
d'animaux que nous ne pouvons pas
prendre ce que vous savez que nous on
les euthanasie pas et que nous ne
pouvons pas donc proposé l'adoption
parce qu'on est déjà on est là on est
déjà à saturation
alors j'ai dans le secteur de avant
l'adoption ou l'achat aurore bergé dans
cette loi vous identifier aussi
différents types de maltraitance il ya
là volontaires ces vidéos souvent
ignoble qu'on peut voir sur les réseaux
sociaux de personnes maltraitant des
animaux milieux houssine maltraitance
qui est lié à
méconnaissance et ça avait été demandée
par les associations il va y avoir un
certificat de connaissances c'était
souhaité par 84% des français
mais qu'est ce que c'est il y aura un
questionnaire à répondre une interro on
repassera comment ça va se passer
en fait est ce que vous dites est très
jeu c'est à dire qu'on a à la fois de la
maltraitance volontaires c'est-à-dire
celles et ceux qui ont envie d'être
cruel qui a envie de d'infliger des
sévices à des animaux ces vidéos
terrifiante que l'on voit vous avez un
char qui passe un chien qui électrocuté
en plus des gens qui ce film et qui en
font la promo sur les réseaux sociaux et
ça nous allons le sanctionner beaucoup
plus fortement que ce n'était le cas
aujourd'hui à outils des gens qui
deviennent maltraitant sans le vouloir
par ce que il n'avait pas pris
conscience en amont de ce que signifiait
la charge d'un animal parce que pour
vous pouvez faire la question d'un
cheval par exemple ce sont des coûts
vétérinaire extrêmement important et
vous avez peut-être les meilleures
intentions du monde mais si vous êtes
m'a préparé si vous n'êtes pas
accompagné si vous n'avez pas la
connaissance de ce que cela va engendrer
eh bien vous devenez sans le souhaitait
être devenait maladie
c'est pareil pour un chien au pour un
chat parce que tous les chiens ne sont
pas adaptés en fonction de la
composition de votre foyer de votre
famille en fonction de nos
disponibilités en fonction du lieu
d'habitation qui est le vôtre et donc
l'idée c'est qu'est ce certificat de
reconnaissance préalable pour vérifier
en vérité que vous êtes apte évidemment
mais surtout que vous avez mesurer
l'engagement que vous allez prendre
parce que quand on adopte un animal quel
qu'il soit c'est pour toute la vie de
l'animal et donc on s'engage pour dix
ans pour 15 ans parfois plus et c'est ça
quand il faut être conscient au moment
de l'adoption juste peut-être un bon
parce que la question des fourrières a
été évoquée lequel on a avancé dans la
loi jusqu'à aujourd'hui en garder un
animal en cours hier que huit jours on a
considéré que c'est trop y avait pas un
travail suffisant qui a été fait par
crainte de certaines souris hier à les
rechercher les propriétaires de ce qu'il
pouvait être en voyage ou autre et c'est
arrivé j'en suis tout d'un coup en
situation de détresse dans tout leur
animal être euthanasié parce qu'ils
n'ont pas été contacté parce qu'ils ne
savaient pas vers qui se tourner
qu'on a allongé le délai ce sera
maintenant de deux semaines et on a mis
aussi l'obligation formation ou bien
être animal
pour les personnes qui travaillent en
fut rien là aussi c'est jean jacques
sahel fombonne ce genre de questionnaire
de certificats vous le métier quasiment
une place à la spa quand on arrive on a
un questionnaire à répondre savoir si on
sait répondre
la durée de vie d'un chat notamment les
besoins d'un chien mais comment vous
allez ce père vous arrivez à associer
vos protégés qui souvent ou un passé
difficile aux demandeurs alors ils n'ont
pas forcément un passé difficile cd
enfin ils ont pas forcément été
maltraités ces désagréments on peut nous
abandonner simplement parce que je
dirais les gens on hérite par exemple
ils peuvent pas les garder mais c'est
pour ça qu'on est content de la
cohérence de cette loi on avait peur que
ce certificat dans la mesure où la vente
en animalerie aurait perduré ne soit
vous savez comme l'attestation google
que vous signez parce qu'évidemment vous
ne misez pas avec 80 pages est tout
petit vous signez j'accepte et je
continue ce qui n'avait pas de sens
en revanche à partir du moment où on va
chez un éleveur est chez nous ça existe
déjà depuis de nombreuses années ça
prend tout son sens
qu'est ce qui se passe et ce que dit
madame berger c'est à dire vous avez des
gens qui arrive avec une idée ils ont vu
un médecin aujourd'hui un berger
allemand
ils ont flashé sur l'animal viennent on
va les interroger
c'est pas un examen mais on va leur
demander dans quelles conditions du
livre qui est à la maison
à quelle heure il part que matin qu'elle
rentre le soir quelles sont leurs
revenus évidemment pas de façon à de
façon indiscrètes non leur disant voilà
ça peut vous coûter tant par mois c'est
un animal qui peut être malade avec le
temps vous avez gardé dix quinze ans
maintenant je pense que votre idée
préconçue de prendre ce gros chien par
exemple n'est pas forcément la bonne
venez nous allons faire autour de refuge
et puis dans 99 99 % des cas les gens
voient un autre animal qui leur plaît
ils nous écoutent et partent avec et
c'est une opération de bonheur
réciproque
il est à ma connaissance i s'est jamais
produit le cas de personnes qui restent
bloqués sur 1 à nîmes
et qu'ils veuillent pas nous écouter
donc effectivement ce certificat prend
tout son sens et on voit très peu
d'actes de maltraitance actifs
c'est plutôt de la maltraitance par
ignorance par délaissement on a eu l'an
dernier nous à la spa pour la seule
association
donc je préside donc plus de 14000
signalement mais ça a donné lieu à
quelques centaines de de capture
d'animaux de réquisition judiciaire qui
nous ont demandé de protéger les ennemis
en allons les chercher chez des
particuliers ou chez des éleveurs
indélicat de façon à les mettre à l'abri
on est donc dans un rapport qui est qui
et quand même heureusement très faible
entre les actes de maltraitance de
cruauté actifs et les actes de deux on
va dire de d'abandon chez soi d'animaux
pas nour il pas soigné pas à pabré on va
à promener justement dimanche encore
dans l'émission à nous à adopter les
responsables des refus des refuges de
plaisir et renouer se rendent chez une
personne complètement dépassé et il
découvre plus de 70 ch à aurore bergé
aussi par ce certificat
on sensibilise à la stérilisation des
animaux et on sait que quand on va dans
un refuge y sera stérilisé l'animal
arthur et faut le dire et le redire
c'est absolument pas être cruel envers
un animal que de les stériliser c'est
même une nécessité absolue notamment qui
concerne les chats parce que tu fais de
regarder les lignes et que les chats
peuvent produire il n'y a pas de
stérilisation ça devient ensuite un défi
sanitaire que l'on a à régler vous voyez
bien les chats errants dans un certain
nombre de nos communes on va dans la loi
le renforcer parce qu'on va donner
obligations au maire de stériliser les
chairs et ça je crois que c'est aussi
extrêmement important on a besoin
clairement que toutes les collectivités
s'engagent à faire soit au niveau de la
commune soit au niveau des
intercommunalités pour les plus petites
d'entre elles et on a besoin d'état
viendra aussi les accompagner dans la
prise en charge mais je crois que c'est
une responsabilité à la fois
individuelle de la personne qui est
propriétaire d'un animal met en place
défaut de cette responsabilité alors les
communes sans charge parce que encore
une formidable
opération de réduire ce nom donc c'est
pas être maltraitant en vraiment
vis-à-vis de son animal que stérilisés
bien au contraire et d'ailleurs c'était
un des premiers à les réaliser un dans
dans les refuges vous n'êtes votre
animal qui ne serait pas pérennisés
jacques charles coombes est ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer aussi des chez vous
comme chez vous des délégués qui se
rendent dans des habitations non on a
une carte de propriétaire d'animal pour
vérifier que tout va bien parce qu' un
enfant on peut peut-être détecter des
masses de la maltraitance à l'école on
peut se rendre compte
un animal il est dans un foyer parfois
fermé g7 semblait enquêteurs qui sent
dès qu'ils sont des bénévoles qui vont
chez des particuliers alors souvent sur
le signalement effectivement de gens qui
nous disent écoutez voilà là
manifestement un problème près de chez
moi parce que je vois tel animal
toujours attaché toujours en plein
soleil et à ce moment on y va la plupart
du temps mais ça va dans la suite de ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure la plupart
du temps on explique aux gens de façon
pédagogique ou revient choses ont changé
mais souvent où on a affaire
effectivement des gens qui sont dépassés
par la situation et on leur suggère de
nous confier l'animal est à ce moment où
le maire dans un de nos refuges et on le
donne à l'adoption une fois qu'on l'a
effectivement stérilisés une fois qu'on
l'a on l'a vacciné et qu'il est allé
dans une angine fallu alors chaque
semaine on questionne aussi nos
téléspectateurs sur la question de
l'émission cette semaine c'était là
juste il doit la justice pardon
doit-elle être plus sévères contre la
maltraitance animale
la réponse est bien sûr oui à 80 9% hors
berger on l'a dit vite fait les
sanctions elles peuvent être très
élevées on peut monter jusqu'à cinq ans
d'emprisonnement jusqu'à soixante quinze
mille euros danone est ce que ce sera
appliqué où on est dans la dissuasion
alors on nage lorsque la loi elle change
la donne encore une fois dans la vision
on a d'un animal la responsabilité et
l'engagement qui est le nôtre vis-à-vis
de l'animal et la loi est là aussi pour
envoyer un message très clair il n'y
aucune impunité envers celles et ceux
qui se rendent coupables
ces vices de cruauté envers les animaux
et donc on vient renforcer de manière
très nette les sanctions je me disais
aujourd'hui dans la loi quand vous venez
volontairement
c'est une saison au moins important que
de est quelqu'un que d'aller chez son
voisin en animal ces grecs évidemment ça
ne pouvait pas perdu tu après il ya ce
responsable
jusqu'à aux rennais la mort de l'animal
donc hier je pense en effet clairement
dissuasif mais je le dis aussi on a
besoin que une terre de la justice nous
aide parce que sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres on attend de voir une réponse
pénale exemplaire et il faut aussi que
les prises de conscience il est très
clair parlement table s'en sont emparés
je crois que la loi maintenant une fois
qu'elle sera définitivement adoptée mais
telle qu'elle a été adoptée à
l'assemblée
elle est très claire il va falloir aussi
cultiver nos jeunes le pen sont
prononcés le choix russie est justement
par un tribunal il y à un élan courtois
qui lancé en octobre dernier une
pétition pour demander la création d'un
tribunal consacré à la maltraitance
animale pour juger en comparution
immédiate les maîtres coupable de
cruauté envers les animaux
jacques fontbonne ça peut être une piste
aussi ce que la la le service de
protection animale de les spectres est
quand même plus de 300 plaintes et se
constitue partie civile dont plus de 300
audiences chaque année est-ce que s'il
ya un tribunal juste pour les animaux on
pourrait peut-être aller plus vite et
make les femmes aiment et de 450 l'an
dernier mais non ça me paraît pas être
une bonne idée je pense que l'arsenal
l'arsenal juridique actuel permet ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que c'est une
infraction délictuelle donc c'est une
criminelle correctionnel ça veut dire un
casier judiciaire ça veut dire ensuite
l'impossibilité par exemple d'accéder à
la fonction publique mais alors mais
soumis aux procédures pénales sont déjà
un peu anciens malheureusement mais à
partir du moment où il s'agit d'un délit
ou les faits ne sont pas contestés
je pense qu'il n'y a aucune raison que
personne ne puisse pas
puisse pas passer dans le tribunal
correctionnel en comparution immédiate
il faut des réussites sur le quantum de
la peine je pense qu'avec les nouvelles
infractions
on doit rentrer dans le cadre de la
comparution immédiate dont le look
après c'est une question d'appréciation
des juges du fond évidemment les peines
sont très sévères et comme le dit ma
d'un berger un vrai signal de la part du
législateur
après les juges du fond sont souverains
on ne juge pas défaire on juge toujours
une personne qui a commis des faits donc
la palette de la répression est
extrêmement variée et puis pour avoir
passé 35 ans dans la gendarmerie
je suis pas convaincu au delà du signal
au-delà du symbole que la véritable
effectivité de la peine nous nous avons
pris à l'espère le parti de l'éducation
on va dans les écoles on va voir les
tout petits enfants de façon à ce que le
respect de l'animal centre de façon de
façon profonde dans leur façon d'être et
je dis souvent que lorsque les enfants
diront à leurs parents c'est pas bien ce
que tu fais aux chiens ou chats à ce
moment là on aura gagné
alors là on a beaucoup parlé des animaux
domestiques les chats les chiens ou
encore les lapins et tous les nac qu'on
peut rencontrer mais dans la loi il y
aussi les animaux sauvages les animaux
non domestiques
aurore bergé le texte prévoit notamment
l'interdiction de leur exploitation dans
les cirques et dans les émissions de
télévision notamment
il fallait aussi passé par là
oui parce que tout l'enjeu d'éducation
de sensibilisation qui vient d'être
présentée passe aussi par la
représentation qu'on a de ces animaux on
n'est pas contre la question de la
captivité
on n'est pas sur le même plan par
exemple les eaux et les siècles dans
l'accueil d'un certain nombre d'animaux
sauvages
est ce qu'on sait aussi les défis qui
existent l'adp d'éducation voire même de
soutien de préservation d'un certain
nombre d'espèces par contre on sait
qu'ils les espèces qui sont complètement
inadaptés à la vie en captivité est
d'autant plus cirque itinérant il voyait
mal sur les routes du thé les lions des
éléphants sont dans des cages toute la
journée ça n'est pas la vocation de ces
années c'est vrai car en changement
aussi on la rapporte que l'on a aux
animaux sauvages je suis parti une
génération ou enfants c'est vrai que mes
grands parents m'emmenaient voir des
cires capec des agneaux pour me faire
plaisir
lui ça m'émerveillais enfants de voir un
lyon ou un éléphant mais qu' aujourd'hui
avec le recul que nous avons avec le
voilà les changements aussi qui existent
y compris dans nos propres mentalité on
voit maintenant cela n'a plus du tout et
qu'il fallait en sortir
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place cette
loi et puis la même chose dans les
émissions de télévision on voit bien
caractère complètement incongrue même
dangereux dans la présentation trop
d'impôts d'un bébé tigre sur un plateau
de télévision
c'est un an jouer et la loi elle est
aussi là pour envoyer de message clair
un animal par jour est l'animal a une
responsabilité que nous avons nous avons
des responsabilités envers les animaux
et donc nous avons des responsabilités
qui doivent justifier la manière avec
laquelle nous devons les traiter et les
comptes y verrez jacques fontbonne
justement sur cette question des animaux
sauvages non domestiques est ce que vous
attendez plus que ça notamment dans le
sujet au début
christophe marie le porte parole de la
fondation brigitte bardot confiait que
la loi ne répondait pas à toutes leurs
attentes ils attendaient aussi la chasse
la chasse à courre la corrida alors
effectivement la loi répond pas à tous
mais c'est quand même je pense que c'est
vraiment un texte fondateur
c'est vraiment un texte comme on n'en a
peut-être pas eu avec un périmètre aussi
large depuis depuis la loi grammont au
19e siècle
manifestement pour nous un spa et nous
avons d'ailleurs assignées devant leurs
tribunaux correctionnels les villes
taurines les organisateurs électoraux
pour nous la prochaine étape c'est très
clairement la corrida parce qu'on y est
il faut que le dispositif législatif
soit incohérent
c'est à dire comment pourrait-on accepté
au japon comment pourrait-on à interdire
les animaux dans les cirques
comment pourrait-on interdire je dirais
la maltraitance par le propriétaire est
accepté ou au motif d'une tradition
qu'ils ont fait n'est pas une pascal aka
la corrida et non pas la course de
taureaux mais la corrida a été importée
d'espagne
adam un petit peu plus de 100 ans
comment peut-on accepter dans ces
circonstances que l'on est un spectacle
précédé de torture est suivie de mort
avec un animal que l'on va que l'on va
blesser suffisent à vous quand qu'ils
deviennent moins dangereux mais assez
peu quand même pour le pot que le
spectacle puisse durer le plus longtemps
possible
ils savent être un combat ça sera
peut-être le dernier combat de la
protection de la protection animale des
années qui viennent mais nous sommes
nous s p a engagé de façon résolue est
bon la protection animale c'est un
combat de longue haleine
je suis certain qu'on y arrivera je suis
déjà certain qu'on va imposer
l'interdiction aux mines d'entrer dans
l'est dans les arènes c'est un spectacle
de mort je ne suis pas certain que voir
donné la mort un animal soit un bon
message des parents dans la construction
affective d'un consultant psychique est
plus petit or berger on va terminer avec
vous en quelques secondes
est ce que il y aura une prochaine étape
sur cette loi notamment dans les
yvelines c'est une terre de chasse à
courre est ce que ça pourrait être votre
prochain combat où la corrida comme dit
monsieur fombonne alors vous savez déjà
la prochaine étape elle veut être un
scénario pour moi j'ai ensuite les
citoyens les associations à mobiliser
les chaînes à tort sur ce sujet là pour
que déjà la loi telle qu'elle a été
votée puisse être renforcées dans
twilight mais en aucun cas puisse être
amoindrie mais j'aimerais la loi qui
arrivera qui sortira du sénat elles
sortent pas sans la question des six
lire que sont la question d une rupture
sur la question des fourrières et c'est
donc déjà on va y avoir une mobilisation
il faut maintenir cette pression cette
scène création citoyenne et des
associations brrr ça dans des villes de
président du sénat j'espère qu'il sera
en soutien de cette vente qui est aussi
une demande formulée par beaucoup d'élus
le court par exemple la question de
l'adoption des animaux sauvages dans les
cirques ya énormément de moeurs qui
avait pris des arrêtés en disant nous
sur notre commune ne souhaite pas
accepter ce tir de cire
malheureusement ces arrêtés légaux il
n'avait pas de base légale demain eh
bien ils seront protégés et sur la
corrida à manger pas réagi clairement
les points de vue
il a fallu tu avais une loi c'est aussi
un compromis pour faire en sorte puisse
être à l'ordre du jour votre assemblée
je sens certains mais encore une fois
j'aimerais que chacun mesure le pas
énorme de fer en chine
j'espère vraiment sera en appuyant et il
y aura de la corrida article on va
s'arrêter sur ces mots merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté notre invitation
il y a toujours autant de compagnons
adopté ne serait ce que dans les
yvelines la spa ces trois refuges en a
merci de nous avoir suivis vous pourrez
trouver cette émission sur notre site
internet ou d'applications mobiles on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine prenez
soin de vous
[Musique]